Its like the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade out here Jimmy J
You hired me from a want Ad
You think that comes with superpower
Grimlock drop the cruiser right now
That is an alien dinosaur
[Screaming]
Hey! Where are the keys!?!
I'm just gonna have to hot wire this bitch
You are needed sir
Urgently
You want to know don't you?
Why they keep coming here.
So, is this a kidnapping or her first transformer experience?
Its both really
1000 years, they have kept this hidden
The secret history of transformers
Here...  on earth
Now to save our future
We must unlock the past
You better have some skills today buddy
Oh!
Look... I love you man
What are you doing?
Dying
That was a bean bag...  i felt that go through me
Two worlds colliding
Only one survives
Hang on!
I'll stay
and I want to fight them
What was that
That was a Mistake
Filmed with IMax 3D cameras